bruno retailleau le président des
sénateurs les républicains et nouveau
président de la région les pays de la
loire est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir soit émotions merci d'être avec
nous pour ce rendez vous donc de public
sénat avec la fp vous aurez l'occasion
par chacune des parties de répondre à
trois grandes questions premièrement
selon vous le gouvernement est il en
panne d'autorité nous avons connu une
journée de manifestations tous azimuts
dire mais avec des violences du côté des
taxis et puis bien sûr vous vous
réclamez spécifiquement un passage à
l'acte est à l'action à notre dame des
landes 1 au lendemain d'une décision de
justice importante
deuxième question est ce que vous
voterez oui à l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution vous le dirai tout à
l'heure à oriane mancini de public sénat
alors que manuel valls appelle
aujourd'hui au rassemblement le plus
large sur le fameux article 2
controversé sur la déchéance qui
pourrait ne plus faire mention de la
binationalité puisque le premier
ministre dit viser qu'une seule
catégorie de français vous l'avez
entendu les terroristes enfin troisième
question est-ce que vous condamnez le
revirement de nicolas sarkozy dans son
livre sur le mariage pour tous vous qui
avez été et qui demeurait sans doute un
des plus fervents opposants à cette
mesure du gouvernement c'est guillaume
daudin qui vous interrogera tout à
l'heure sur ce sujet et d'autres en
rapport avec les candidats à la primaire
de la droite et du centre alors la
première question donc est ce que le
gouvernement selon vous êtes en panne
d'autorité quand des manifestations se
déroulent parfois avec des violences du
côté des taxis en plein état d'urgence
écoutez il ya des manifestations pour
moi elles sont plutôt le symbole d'une
crise d'une crise du modèle français
alors on vit une révolution numérique
notamment avec l'ubs et risation
libéralisation c'est aussi une fiscalité
qui échappe à l'état et en même temps
les taxis sont soumises à une fiscalité
à décharge qui sont parmi les plus
lourdes en europe parce que notre modèle
fiscal à nous c'est le matraquage fiscal
donc ça ne peut pas coller et on voit
bien qu'à un moment donné les raisons
objectives pour l'effectif mal il avait
raison en tout cas il ya un certain
nombre de raisons aucune raison ne
justifie évidemment la violence
simplement ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est aussi la méthode de françois
hollande qui est en cause
parce que l'indécision ou plutôt le flou
le flottement les revirements les yo-yo
je crois que cela encourage finalement
au plus haut niveau de l'état
une forme d'incertitude de d'hésitation
et c'est propice à en même temps un
manque d'autorité je vais prendre un
exemple que je connais bien c'est notre
dame des landes
on va en parler en détail on vante vous
interroger sur la fumée en tout cas le
notre dame des landes aux différentes
manifestations et au plus haut niveau
d'états je pense que cette indécision
ces inondations favorisent oui elle
favorise le point commun à toutes les
colères qui s'expriment des taxis aux
enseignants en passant par régulière du
ciel c'est la décision le point commun
le point commun je voulais des éleveurs
la crise c'est la crise d'un modèle
économique est essoufflé et je pense que
malheureusement et lors de tous les
secteurs de l'économie il va alors oui
dans beaucoup de secteurs d'économies
mais mon prix le feu il ya une
paupérisation il ya une paupérisation
des français
la france est à la traîne désormais
quand on voit la richesse des français
rapportés au nombre d'habitants
nous sommes 7 % de moins que la moyenne
européenne ça devrait nous interroger et
là aussi c'est l'indécision françois
hollande qui n'a pas su faire ce que
tous les grands pays européens en fait
c'est à dire réforme et pourquoi est ce
que la france est le seul des grands
pays européens à ne pas avoir connu deux
recrues du chômage de diminution du
chômage depuis un peu plus d'un an tout
simplement parce que nous n'avons pas
fait les réformes en que tous les grands
pays ont fait le plein tout ramener ce
que vous dénoncez comme la décision du
chef de l'état par exemple les
fonctionnaires ils seront dans la rue
aujourd'hui
ils dénoncent le gel de leurs points
dadis depuis six ans donc une décision
qui avait été prise par la droite et là
pour le coup là françois hollande n'a
pas varié on peut les gagner là rien
changé oui mais je vais vous expliquer
les fonctionnaires sont en train d'être
paupérisée pourquoi sont ils en train
d'être popularisé notamment je parle des
instituteurs je parle d'un certain
nombre de professions qui exerçait qui
exerce toujours une sorte de magistère
en france tout simplement parce que ils
sont trop nombreux
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon avait
commencé à diminuer de 150 mille le
nombre de fonctionnaires pour pouvoir
les payer plus donc on un choix soit on
augmente toujours plus sa fonction
publique et dans la situation que le
pays connaît ça voudra dire un
appauvrissement général soit on fait
différemment c'est à dire que on
économise en termes de postes mais aussi
il faudra sans doute faire
déverrouillez et faire sauter le blocage
des 35 heures parce que ça permettra
pour l'hôpital de respirer de mieux
organiser l'hôpital de mieux rémunérer
les gens et on retrouvera à nouveau un
chemin de croissance et un chemin de
convergence à propos des 35 heures
justement et le débat est sur la table
manuel valls s'est également exprimé sur
le sujet est ce que vous vous estimez
qu'il ne faut pas payer plus cher les
heures travaillées au delà de 35 heures
par exemple vous ah mais moi je suis
pour très clairement la fin des 35
heures et là on assista est-ce que vous
êtes pour la fin des des heures
supplémentaires je suis pour que dans
chaque entreprise
on puisse définir dans un cadre alors ça
peut être trente neuf heures la nouvelle
par exemple la nouvelle durée légale du
temps de travail c'est à partir à ce
moment là d'accord
40e heures je suis favorable bien sûr
pour contre 35 et 39 les gens puissent
payer des heures qu'il ferait même je le
pense je pense qu'en tout cas ce que je
souhaite moi c'est que on est d accord
de branche ou même des référendum dans
l'entreprise c'est je pense la façon
moderne demain de pouvoir est connue fin
de pouvoir réaliser l'économie c'est le
parti des propositions économiques que
vous avez mis sur la table récemment et
qui trouve écho d'ailleurs excusé
aujourd'hui le blocage donc aller dans
certains grands magasins parisiens qui
n'arrive pas à passer au travail le
dimanche
par contre il n'ya pas de référendum
garder sur les 35 heures regardez la
cacophonie regarder chacun joue sa
partition entre le premier ministre
entre emmanuel macron on ne s'y retrouve
plus on n'a pas un orchestre on n'a pas
un chef d'orchestre
on a des solistes donc quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure que cette méthode
de françois hollande qui consiste à
jouer des uns sur les autres qui
consiste à ne pas trancher était
porteuse finalement d'anxiété je crois
que vous avez souligné qu'avec les 35
heures on a un vrai problème
alors que d'ailleurs à propos des 35
heures au site emmanuel macron vous avez
vu le baromètre doxa qui a été publiée
ce matin
il le montre deuxième derrière alain
juppé chez les sympathisants de droite
vous le placez aussi autant on est
humble ministre de l'économie il
transgresse un certain nombre d'idées
reçues de la gauche manuel valls avait
ce rôle-là souvenez vous quand même que
manuel valls au moment notamment des
primaires de la gauche était l'homme qui
voulait transgresser et qui voulait
bousculer les 35 heures
et du coup bon emmanuel macron bien sûr
c'est briser là et je pense que il a une
forme de courage simplement
j'avais dénoncé au moment de sa loi
l'almanach rond que il parlait fort mais
qu' on lui permettait pas d'agir
beaucoup pour se déployer vraiment
bouger dit venez bien avec nous c'est
pas mon problème
le débauchage très peu pour moi
s'il a des convictions il en a il doit
les confronter avec ce qu'il observe
et si à un moment donné il ya un trop
grand écart ce sera à lui de faire ses
choix alors en matière d'autorité on ne
revient comment devrait-elle s'appliquer
selon vous à calais avec la fameuse
jungle et puis on a vu ce week-end une
manifestation une contre-manifestation
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy appelle
l'état et le gouvernement à agir pour
éviter la chienlit que faire bien sûr
que faire un call est que faire à notre
dame des landes faire respecter l'état
de droit
c'est incroyable qu'on puisse en arriver
par exemple la fermeture d'un port voilà
pourquoi parce que la justice n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens il faut que le
tribunal ne soient pas à boulogne mais
puisse être à calais pour pouvoir juger
rapidement il faut une fermeté dans les
décisions de justice qu'est ce que vous
voulez comme condamné un migrant un
sans-papiers à une amende de 3 ou 4000
euros quand il est insolvable
c'est une peine qui ne lui dis alors
pour éviter la chienlit coiffe envoyé
l'armée
je suis pas pour envoyer d'argent parce
que j'ai toujours considéré que papa le
nombre de l'armée je le sais je le
voulais je le sais mais je considère que
l'armée a une fonction une mission et un
rôle et les forces de l'ordre police et
gendarmerie en nantes un autre
alors maintenant on arrive à un autre
dossier dans lequel vous êtes très
impliqué est ce que vous croyez à
l'expulsion des opposants à l'aéroport
notre dame des landes donc la justice je
le disais tout à l'heure à valider les
procédures d'expulsion des habitants et
des opposants historiques en fallait
encore un délai de deux mois
est ce que vous croyez là encore un
geste d'autorité puisque vous le
réclamer sur tous les sujets a ajouté je
le réclame j'ai entendu cet après midi
manuel valls répondent madame duflot
madame duflot qui devrait d'ailleurs se
préoccuper des riverains qui subissent
des violences des à dist qui sont des
ultra-violents notera des landes c'est
simple c'est une zone de non droit où
l'autorité de l'état ne s'appliquent
plus je vais vous donner un exemple très
simple les riverains en avait tellement
marre qu une
une femme a décidé de faire une pétition
elle a brisé la loi du silence et les en
avaient marre les artisans etc
les commerçants et bien on lui a saccagé
vendredi soir sa maison moi je veux
aller dans cette maison montrer mon
soutien comme président du conseil
régional des pays-de-la-loire et bien la
préfecture on dit surtout n'y allez pas
on est incapable gérer jurés votre
sécurité aux jurés et je suis allé à
notre dame des landes et on ne voulait
pas que j'aille à notre-dame-des-landes
on vous a grêlé j'aille plus loin qu'est
ce que c'est que ce pays où un élu de la
république ne peut plus se déplacer
librement parce que on a une forme de
guérilla et je crois que il faut que
désormais parce qu'on a une nouvelle
décision de justice des choses sont
désormais claires il faut arrêter les
pillages les saccages du centre ville de
nantes
les gendarmes qui sont attaqués les
voitures gendarmerie qui sont brûlés les
journalistes qui sont aussi molesté
michel brault soeur et moi je veux que
la loi s'applique en loire atlantique et
à notre indolence je demande
l'évacuation et je demande la le
commencement des travaux pour les
reports vous l'avez dit cécile duflot a
interpellé le premier ministre sur cette
question et elle a utilisé également cet
argument concernant les reports on
l'écouté vous réagissez aucune
préoccupation d'intérêt général ne
légitiment plus la construction d'un
projet d'aéroport qui date de 1963
chacun le sait aujourd'hui ce projet
symbolise pour nos compatriotes
l'entêtement aveugle et 20 à promouvoir
des grands projets inutiles
chacun sent bien d'ailleurs que ce qui
se joue là bas dépasse le simple cadre
de notre dame des landes ce projet
d'aéroport est désormais la preuve du
retard démocratique français de
l'obstination technocratique et de la
négation de l'écologie alors elle
dénonce un entêtement donc vain le
votrient et d'autres dans la région
depuis des années a vu son pouvoir un
projet inutile bien sûr alors projets
inutiles projet soutenu par trois
présidents de républiques successivement
de droite et de gauche projets soutenus
par six premiers ministres projets
soutenus par plusieurs maires de nant
par plusieurs présidents mais les temps
ont changé oui ou non les régions gg
vous dire justement l'an dernier notre
dame
enfin l'aéroport actuel a été celui et
c'est déjà le cas depuis dix ans en
europe par rapport aux autres
plateformes aéroportées
r c'est l'ayraultport nantes atlantique
où le trafic augmente le plus on a eu
cent trente huit journées de saturation
donc on voit bien que les écolos ne
voudrait sans doute plus d'aéroports en
france vous que on n'emprunte plus qu'on
ne développe plus ce moyen de transport
ça c'est un débat c'est un débat
démocratique
mais j'observe que ce projet a une
légitimité économique
c'est fondamental pour l'emploi pour la
croissance dans le grand ouest pour la
bretagne jean yves le drian le soutien
comme moi pour les pays de la loire
il a une légitimité démocratique droite
et gauche ont le soutien
voilà on parle souvent de consensus là
vous avez un consensus droite gauche et
enfin il ya des décisions de justice
on a désormais 154 vous m'entendez bien
154 décision de justice favorable au
transfert aéroport de nantes at il ya
plus de rue à nos adhérents
alors je souhaiterais que madame duflot
non tout est rigoureusement les textes
sont rigoureusement évidemment respecter
et la commission européenne a eu à
connaître et à donner son accord
simplement je voudrais qu'on aime duflot
puisse avoir une oreille attentive aux
souffrances des riverains voilà
simplement je le lui demande
très très sereinement on n'oublie pas
celle des gens qui sont attachés à leur
terre non plus ils vont devoir partir
par mois depuis cinq générations d'une
belle encore plus de écoutez il ya plus
de 200 personnes qui fêtait des
habitants historiques qui ont si j'ose
dire donner leur accord à l'amiable
il ya quatre agriculteurs sur une
quarantaine qui ont été récalcitrants je
comprends que ça leur fasse mal et je ne
mésestime pas leur souffrance simplement
dans une démocratie un état de droit il
ya des décisions de justice c'est le
moyen de sortir de la violence c'est le
moyen de trancher des différents parce
que ce que ne dit pas madame duflot et
beaucoup d'écologie c'est que il
s'appuie sur la zad évidemment pour
combattre les reports et ça c'est
inacceptable parce que la zad comme l'a
dit le premier ministre je le rejoins
totalement sur les noms des
ultra-violents et j'ajoute ce sont des
ultra gauchiste alors quand même il ya
des propos quand même qu'ils qui sembla
alarmiste pour l'avenir exemple sur
publicsenat.fr josé bové dit qu'il peut
y avoir des troubles beaucoup plus grave
encore à l'ordre public le chantage et
la violence je sais le chantage du
chantage à la violence c'est un chantage
à la viole
les riverains qui ont fait il ya
quelques semaines qui ont brisé cette
loi du silence parce qu'il ya une loi du
silence et que à chaque fois que un
certain nombre de citoyens qui
respectueux de la loi et le droit
veulent sortir justement de cette loi du
silence
ils subissent des représailles eh bien
il ya eu des représailles voilà est-ce
que monsieur bové soutient ce genre de
représailles
est ce que monsieur beauvais signifie
qu' il faut que ceux qui sont dans la
zad s'opposent aux forces de l'ordre y
compris avec des moyens violents
représentants parce que certains disent
également dans le camp des opposants que
s'il ya une expulsion manu militari à
après le 26 mars
il pourrait y avoir un drame plus grave
qu à 6,20 s'il y avait eu un mort et
chantage bien sûr c'est du chantage je
ne le souhaite pas mais on est encore
une fois dans un état de droit la
république c'est la loi est ce c'est la
justice qui dit la loi
quand la justice répète inlassablement
un certain nombre de décisions il faut
que la loi reste je crois le critère de
partage entre les anti et les et les
pour voilà c'est tout est ce que vous
croyez pas que le délai de deux mois qui
a été accordée avant le départ par la
justice me soit mise à profit se sont
parlés posant les opposants pour
radicaliser les positions non moi je
pense que quand il ya des travaux des
frigos renforcer la mobilisation des
travaux de défrichage affaire il ya une
route à commencer donc on peut
parfaitement commencer les travaux avant
même d'atteindre ces maisons je
comprends que il ya une situation de
droit moi je suis très respectueux
la décision du juge est elle est celle
là il ya jusqu'au 26 mars pour que ces
gens là puissent rester dans leur maison
et ils ont ce délai ensuite ni devons
finalement partir ailleurs
alors je vous entends avec des mesures
d'accompagnement temps de défendre ce
projet je vous entend dénoncer les
opposants j'ai l'impression de
réentendre manuel valls répondant à
cécile duflot a écouté j'ai j'ai vu deux
fois manuel valls sur ce projet quelques
jours après d'ailleurs que j'ai été élu
président du conseil régional
il m'avait tenus en privé les mêmes
propos et en vous lui dites chapeau
basque oui je lui dis chapeau je pense
qu'alors je vais vous dire j'ai aucun
doute sur la volonté de manuel valls
aucun doute j'ai une petite incertitude
désormais sur la décision
un peu plus haut du président ben ali
pour ramener sur la décision du chef
2011 il ya une cacophonie là encore au
sommet de l'exécutif oui il ya ségolène
royal qui fait semble réticente
déclaration voilà façon très autonome il
ya le premier ministre bien sûr qu'ils
aient droit dans ses bottes et qui devra
trancher
c'est françois hollande j'espère qu'il
tranchera et qu' il respectera l'état de
droit la démocratie est un projet
capital pour la croissance j'ai entendu
mois au moment de ses voeux françois
hollande je l' ai entendu proclamé cet
état d'urgence économique bien je dis
monsieur le président si vous êtes
attaché au développement à la croissance
donnée à l'ouest les moyens de son
attractivité territoriale dans leurs
compétitions européennes et mondiales à
vos vous pourrez peut-être lui dire
chapeau en attendant vous dites chapeau
à manuel valls parce que lui il a montré
qu'il n'était pas accommoder avec les
écologistes en vue de 2017
ça c'est ferrer c'est clair un croix
peppler instaure le premier ministre à
des propos qui sont les propos d'un
premier ministre respectueux de l'état
de droit que je veux - promouvoir
est ce que vous verrez françois hollande
le 2 février
bruno retailleau sûr je le verrai le 2
février
vous êtes invités les présidents de
région
à voir le chef de l'état pour parler de
son plan pour l'emploi et la formation
vous irez vous un oui pourquoi vous me
posez cette question quand je suis
invité par le chef de l'état je vois là
je réponds à l'invitation j'attends en
revanche de connaître non pas le menu au
sens du déjeuner mais au sens d'un
certain nombre de points qui devraient
aborder et vous êtes prêt à épauler le
plan qu'il a dévoilé récemment pour
l'emploi à travers notamment le
renforcement de la formation qui a une
de vos prérogatives
absolument c'est le mans moi je pose des
limites
la première limite c'est que je ne
ferais pas et la région des pédales wah
ne financera pas des stages qui seraient
des voies de garage je ne ferai pas du
strate du traitement statistique du
chômage parce que ce serait mentir aux
demandeurs d'emploi j'ai fait des
propositions il ya un moyen parce que ce
que ce qui est choquant moi j'ai
beaucoup d'entreprises qui veulent
recruter qui ne parviennent pas à
recruter et donc on voulait mettre le
paquet sur l'apprentissage veut mettre
le paquet sur l'apprentissage la
formation professionnelle ou si j'arrête
d'entreprise mais sur des formations
d'accord on voulait pas aller à aider
éventuellement un maquillage des
statistiques voisins je comprends bien
me 3d bien là ces financements
refinancement et oui parce que le moment
michel grossiord le temps l'époque où
paris décidée et la province devait
s'exécuter
c'est le 20e siècle ça c'est pas le
temps d'aujourd'hui et je le rappellerai
ah bah oui votre autorité
ben c'est pas pour manifester l'autorité
ça me semble être du bon c'est dans
resident evil
écoutez le prénom république le
gouvernement nous a privés de dizaines
et de dizaines millions d'euros de
baisses de dotations alors il faut pas
qu'en même temps il nous met des
dépenses sur le dos
sipa au moment où il va nous priver de
ressources donc il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue équilibré
moi je vous dis je me sentais plus libre
que d'autres élus de votre ayant conduit
à faire appel à des voix de gauche
à belmont a coûté mon adversaire
effectivement j'avais à la fois le fond
national et j'avais un adversaire de
gauche je me sens moi très très vite
comme j'ai toujours été et pour moi la
politique sur d'autres de votre nom vous
avez absolument pas je les connais tous
et je connais leurs convictions donc je
leur fais confiance
maintenant pour moi la politique ce sont
des convictions et si j'étais élu vous
voyez c'est sûr mais conditions donc
jeunes en rabattre est pas sur ce plan
là le message est passé
voilà deuxièmes parties de preuves par 3
bruno retailleau est ce que vous allez
voter oui à l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution oriane mancini depuis le
sénat donc va vous poser la question
alors que manuel valls appelle
aujourd'hui même au rassemblement le
plus large sur l'article 2 l'article sur
la déchéance qui pourrait ne plus faire
état des binationaux puisque le premier
ministre a écouté le dit ne visait
qu'une seule catégorie de français il
n'est aucunement dans l'intention du
président de la république du
gouvernement de viser telle ou telle
catégorie de citoyens
je suis d'ailleurs à l'écouté de tous
ceux qui peuvent se sentir concerné je
veux rappeler uniquement monsieur le
président schwarzenberg que nous ne
visons qu'une seule catégorie de
citoyens une seule les terroristes qui
par leurs crimes
d'une certaine manière déchire le lien
qu'ils ont pu établir avec la nation je
ferai demain des propositions après tout
cette phase de consultation pour
permettre car c'est la mission que le
président de la république m'a donné le
rassemblement le plus large
rassemblement le plus large qui doit se
faire avec le souci de respecter
pleinement l'engagement du président de
la république pris devant les français
c'est à dire devant le congrès est de
faire en sorte que cette écriture cet
article 2 comme les l'autre rassemble le
plus largement chacun face aux pays doit
prendre ses responsabilités
moi monsieur marcel berne chili prenant
pleinement demain voilà bonsoir au
règlement de chaîner alors
vos questions et votre première question
à bruno retailleau sur cette question
soit en entendant un manuel valls cet
après midi à l'assemblée est ce que vous
comprenez ce qu'il y aura dans ce texte
et surtout ce qu'il n'y aura pas plus
que vous si vous comprenez vous allez
m'expliquer mais j'attends avec beaucoup
d'impatience
dommage parce que demain matin nous en
saurons plus voilà simplement depuis
j'étais au congrès je m'étais d'ailleurs
exprimé à versailles et depuis le
congrès je n'ai pas varié c'était le 16
novembre j'ai dit ce que nous ferons ici
au sénat nous le ferons en fonction de
ce qui est utile pour la sécurité des
français
cet après midi manuel valls à
l'assemblée n'a pas employé le terme de
binationaux est ce que pour vous la
déchéance pour les binationaux sera
écartée je ne le sais pas encore une
fois c'était au premier ministre de nous
le dire j'espère qu'ils nous le dira
demain simplement il ya un engagement
solennels pris par le président de la
république devant l'ensemble des
parlementaires réunis à versailles en
congrès nous entendons que cet
engagement soit respectée il avait dit
deux choses dans la réforme
constitutionnelle ont constitutionnalise
l'état d'urgence très bien et aussi on
fait la déchéance pour les binationaux
il avait indiqué pour les français nés
français
voilà je pense et ça ne me choque pas
pourquoi parce que les binationaux ont
une double allégeance à deux nations à
deux communautés nationales donc devant
cette forme de privilège
ils peuvent aussi perdre une de six
nations et surtout lorsqu'il ya un acte
grave de terrorisme et qu'il se retourne
contre une communauté nationale ça me
paraît aux éditions mais il ya des
doutes qui s'exprime également sur cette
question là mais sperian dans votre camp
on entendu par exemple jean pierre
raffarin puis écouter ce que dit patrick
devedjian a lui il est franchement
contre deux personnes participent aux
mêmes attentats ils sont complices l'un
est binational l'autre ne l'est pas un
seul des deux
sera puni par le fait d'être déchu de la
nationalité française il ya une
discrimination donner sens à l'égard des
français c'est contraire à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui
dit que tous les français naissent
libres et égaux en droits est ce que
c'est vous entendez un instant belles
dents mais est ce que je vais vous dire
c'est l'histoire de l'arroseur arrosé la
des chances pour les binationaux
je pense que françois hollande lorsqu'il
s'est prononcée voulait en quelque sorte
piégée la droite
en réalité il a piégé son propre camp je
vous renvoie quand même ça n'est pas
rien à la haute autorité des tic
présidée par maître mignard quelqu'un en
plus que j'estime pour indiquer pour lui
que cette est un débat qu'il fallait que
la gauche sans doute adoptent d'autres
choses nous il ya quelques voix
simplement il ya eu on nous reproche
souvent les républicains d'être un peu
gaulois de diviser de temps en temps
écoutez il ya eu autour nicolas sarkozy
l'autre jour une réunion et il ya eu une
quasi très forte majorité une case une
amie témoins quelques voix pour que on
accepte tous cette déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux
encore une fois et contrairement à ce
que dit patrick devedjian tout
simplement parce que les binationaux
bénéficie d'un privilège d'une double
allégeance
voilà c'est tout à deux pays et donc
qu'ils soient privés d'une allégeance et
d'une nationalité lorsqu'ils ont commis
avec deux graves
c'est normal par contre les autres
doivent être punis tout autant tout
autant y compris d'ailleurs ils peuvent
aussi être déchus de leurs droits
civiques ça ne me gênerait pas du tout
bas gameiro on vous sent bien qu'à
l'elysée au parti socialiste qui a la
volonté de trouver un compromis une
solution médiane tout simplement zéro
créé comme un langage à rendre une autre
proposition vous restez vraiment leur
vous entendrez serré très fixé sur la
déchéance de nationalité sur les
mondines adn ou alors le considère que
le président de république a pris un
engagement
ça n'est pas rien une réunion en congrès
il a pris devant les parlementaires est
en quelque sorte devant la
représentation nationale
par conséquent mois on a toujours dit
c'est oui si c'est ce cadre là si c'est
un autre cadre le sénat qui bénéficie
d'un droit de veto en matière
constitutionnelle
on est sur ce qu'on appelle un
bicamérisme parfait ya pas le dernier
mot à l'assemblée nationale eh bien on
prendra le pouvoir qui nous est donnée
par la constitution pour amender honda
membres à ce que nous propose ici par
exemple l'assemblée
nous transmis un texte qui n'est pas
conforme à l'engagement du président de
la république nous la vendrons voilà
donc simplement
mais il y aura pas de vote nationales
isation alors mardi de problème la
raison de la république a le vôtre mais
sa conséquence ici présent la public est
pas capable de mettre un peu d'ordre
dans sa propre majorité
il ya quand même une question qui se
pose mais michel le rappeler il ya des
divisions à gauche où la binationalité
pose problème vous m'ont dit si la
binationalité n'est pas inscrite on ne
votera pas est-ce que du coup cette
réforme est vouée à l'échec
elle peut l'être et peut l'être alors il
faut aussi parce qu'on l'a demandé il
faut regarder les textes qui vont
accompagner le texte constitutionnel
puisque le texte constitutionnel la
modifier un article de la constitution
peu importe est renvoyé à notamment une
loi organique donc on a demandé à ce que
tous soient sur la table pour que on l
économie générale du texte
et comme on compare les dispositions qui
nous seront données par la voie
constitutionnelle ou par la voie d'une
autre loi pour que l'on sache où on va
et ce que nous allons voter alors les
choses sont claires
voilà les choses sont claires si c'est
l'engagement du président république au
congrès si oui si ça ne l'est pas ce
sera non en tout cas pour le sénat on à
mandera on dirait pas non brutalement
alors on reviendra au tél tout à l'heure
vous avez dit chapeau à manuel valls est
à vous vous adressez à françois hollande
va vous lui dites vous l'avez traité
d'indécis vous dites que c'est un
tacticien qui va le traiter en sondant
le tapis je n'ai pas traiter l'un des
six simples et non simplement me
l'accusé la décision il est très habile
écoutez il est très habile et là je
trouve que le talent qu'il met souvent
dans l'habileté politique je pense qu'il
ferait mieux de le mettre sous la dent
dans la réforme
sur le ballant risque de se retourner
contre lui si j'aurai je vous soumets
d'affecter j'attendais j'attends demain
oui j'attends demain pour l'instant ce
ceux comme le on me dit c'est que il
proclame son attachement à son
engagement alors pour l'instant je fais
confiance ni titre depuis le début
j'attends demain bruno retailleau est ce
que vous trouvez normal en tant que
parlementaire qu'à la veille de la
présentation de ce texte devant la
commission et après une journée sera
assez station vous ne sachiez toujours
pas c'est un autre problème mais là non
c'est pas très normal
il a complètement raison je préfère
d'ailleurs ce soit vous
qui dit y est plutôt que moi parce que
on va les trouver est ce que ça veut
dire que la journée de consultation de
vendredi n'a servi à rien françois
hollande qui a rencontré tous les
parlementaires un vendredi pour parler
de ce texte je suis pas si ça sert à
grand chose il faut il faut sans doute
consulter là encore réponse demain je
vous dirai demain tant qu' on n'a pas de
réponse crible on n'a pas de réponse que
sur notre dame des landes pour l'instant
on n'a pas de réponse sur calais on n'a
pas de réponse c'est cette méthode de
gouvernement que je conteste alors on a
un premier ministre qui parle fort qui
par le haut et fort avec des postures
souvent très très viril très mais je
pense que il faut à un moment donné qu'
il ya une décision est souvent c'est au
président de la république dans nos
institutions de prendre cette décision
alors l'autre podium excellent état
d'urgence pour noter ou en attendant sa
constitutionnalisation cette
prolongation de l'état d'urgence elle
sera examinée au sénat le 9 février est
ce que vous vous êtes favorable
ecoutez-le encore on va attendre le tec
je suis plutôt favorable
bien sûr parce que j'amenais jamais la
menace jamais la menace n'a été aussi
forte sur notre pays on le sait et quand
on discute avec des responsables de haut
niveau du renseignement des responsables
militaires
un certain nombre ou si deux ministres
ils nous le disent et quand on a ses
consultations avec le premier ministre
quand on voit monsieur cazeneuve quand
on voit le président a publié quand on
les leur employeur on a un retour bien
sûr on a un retour d'information qui est
extrêmement inquiétant donc tant que
nous ne sommes pas sortis de cette
période là il vaut mieux se prémunir
maintenant ça veut pas dire que le sénat
votera les yeux fermés il y aura pas de
blanc seing nous sommes la maison
notamment des libertés individuelles
voilà donc on veut là aussi qui est un
bon équilibre dans le texte évoque
audition on peut le dire je ne pose
aucune condition je ne pose aucune
condition et à l'état d'urgence mais on
veut un contrôle parlementaire qui soit
sérieux les ont considérés comme les
garants de l'état de droit vous
aujourd'hui autant la lenteur en tout
cas je pense qu'il faut que le parlement
mais le sénat la marque du sénat c'est
en même temps la garantie des libertés
individuelles je vous faisais la cnil
par exemple sur les données personnelles
c'est de cela qu'il l'a créé c'est
important aujourd'hui dans un monde
numérique ce que ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est que l'agent
constituer ce sera bien mais ce qui est
beaucoup mieux
c'est le virage en matière pénale parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est souvent dans
l'angélisme dans le laxisme bien donc il
ya un texte de loi qui va passer du
gouvernement et on a cosigné avec
philippe bas j'ai cosigné avec mon
collègue françois zocchetto une
proposition de loi qui va donner des
outils justement au delà de l'état
d'urgence pour que nous puissions de
garantir c'est pas concevable que on
soit perpétuellement dans un état
d'urgence donc il faut se donner des
outils qui garantiront la sécurité des
français et ce sera un arsenal notamment
pénal mais pas seulement pénale je pense
que l on pourra imaginer donner un rôle
plus important aux magistrats du parquet
notamment plutôt qu'au préfet voilà le
curseur en matière de garantie des
libertés individuelles qu'on pourra
faire prévaloir dans le texte qui sera
proposé par philippe bas et mon collègue
françois zocchetto mais on se pose la
question de l'indépendance du parquet
alors ça c'est la réforme
c'est ce duel pourrait maintenant à tout
le moins ce qu'a annoncé françois
hollande 1 lors du pot est soumise en
même temps qu'il voudrait introduire la
réforme du csm dans la révision est ce
que c'est une bonne chose
non autant leur là on a un problème de
méthode le 16 novembre
on apprend sans d'ailleurs que le
président du sénat en était informée si
ce n'est cinq minutes avant qu'il va y
avoir une réforme constitutionnelle
et puis deux mois après on apprend qu'il
ya un nouveau sujet de réforme
constitutionnelle le conseil supérieur
et toujours la quête des trois
cinquièmes de la magistrate non mais je
veux dire pas bientôt leur passage chez
écouter on peut pas toucher à la loi
fondamentale
c'est cet édifice qui régule un certain
nombre de choses le rapport entre les
institutions mais aussi nos libertés
fondamentales
on peut pas toucher à la condi à la loi
fondamentale tous les matins sur le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature je
pense que ça peut compliquer les choses
tout simplement parce que vous savez
parfaitement il ya eu une tentative qui
a déjà avorté puisque il y avait un
texte de l'assemblée un texte du sénat
et que ces deux textes sont très
différents et qu'on n'a pas pu
s'accorder et que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure en matière de loi
constitutionnelle on est sur le même
pied
il n'ya pas d'inégalité on est sur un
pied d'égalité entre l'assemblée et le
sénat
néanmoins moment
révision et je donne elle donne plus de
pouvoirs au parquet ce que ce n'est pas
indispensable de renforcer son
indépendance et de noter cette réforme
alors ça c'est une question il ya deux
sujets dans ce texte il ya la
composition du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et nous avons toujours été
contre au sénat une forme d'une forme de
corporatisme qui aboutirait une forme de
syndicalisation d'ailleurs et je pense
que ça n'est pas pour la justice une
bonne chose et puis il ya la question de
savoir si il doit y avoir encore un lien
entre la chancellerie le pouvoir le
gouvernement
et puis les magistrats du parquet nous
sommes sur ce point là assez divisés
alors je voudrais évoquer avec vous une
polémique qui continuent de dépendre
l'ampleur de l'ampleur depuis ce
week-end c'est canal+ ce soit si vous
avez vu les images vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler qu'à convié
donc sur son plateau en présence de
najat vallaud belkacem un responsable
d'une ong musulmanes 1 qui a refusé
devant les caméras de condamner le
groupe etat islamique et qui apprécie
qu'il ne serrerait pas la main des
femmes est à nouveau la ministre d'une
question nationale a été interpellé
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale sur
ce sujet et elle a justifié le bien son
attitude dans l' écoute on ne débat pas
contre les ennemis de la république on
les combat au les combats et mon combat
est totale il exclu tout dialogue
artificielle et toutes les semaines
mon action se situe au sein de mon
ministère où tout est entrepris pour
démonétisé ses discours et pour défendre
la laïcité c'est le sens de tout ce qui
a été mis en oeuvre pour former les
enseignants pour développer l'éducation
civique et morale pour faire en sorte
que l'on rétablisse des règles claires
sur la laïcité je condamne évidemment
les propos qui ont été tenus par ce
président d'association sur ce plateau
je regrette qu'on lui a offert une
tribune une fois encore l'école est
totalement engagée pour transmettre les
valeurs que nous sommes en train de
défendre car
avant qu'un ennemi de part et d'autre de
cette assemblée je vous invite à ne pas
abîmer ce travail par des polémiques
dérisoires on vient d'entendre un jazz
vallaud belkacem est ce que cette
justification n'arrive pas un peu tard
est-ce qu'elle n'aurait pas dû être plus
ferme dimanche et d'une faute évidemment
c'est une faute
elle dit elle même elle le reconnaît en
quelque sorte puisqu'il dit on n'aurait
jamais dû donner une tribune mais par sa
seule présence
elle a solennisé cette tribune elle
aurait dit partir c'est un salafiste il
a refusé de condamner l'état islamique
on a encore vu sur internet en tout cas
on en a entendu parler je ne les ai pas
vus mais vos collègues vous même vous en
avez fait fait état de ces tueries de
cette barbarie
je pense que canal n'avait pas l'inviter
même s'il ya une course à l'audience
mais la course à l'audience ne justifie
pas tout et malheureusement najat
vallaud belkacem a manqué comment
dirais-je de discernement elle aurait dû
quitter le plateau parce qu' elle ne
représente pas que l'école est elle est
ministre elle représente le gouvernement
elle représentait la france et c'est une
grave défaillance
alors il ya un film salafistes c'est son
nom qui sort demain un documentaire qui
nous met justement en présence de nos
ennemis qui s'expriment devant la caméra
sans autres commentaires il à la
question de savoir si ce documentaire
doit être interdits aux moins de 18 ans
vous n'avez pas vu moi non plus mais bon
il ya eu beaucoup de critiques et qui
présente ce deuxième manche et moi que
vous riez hanche et je ne veux pas me je
ne pas prononcer sachant qu'il ya dans
ce documentaire l'image de l'exécution
du policier mais rabette par les frères
qu agir
alors si c'est le cas alors si c'est le
cas je pense qu'on doit pas le diffuser
tout simplement parce que on voit bien
que la stratégie de cette barbarie de
l'état islamique notamment à travers les
images diffusées sur internet
la stratégie c'est de frapper les
consciences la stratégie elle s'incarne
dans l'image et je pense que plus on
donne à l'état islamique des espaces
médiatiques et bien plus on le sert et
nous sommes en guerre et à la raison
vous adresser aussi et d'abord aux
médias je bien sûr bien sûr ils sont
concernés moi je suis attaché à la
liberté d'expression et vous savez
parfaitement que avec la liberté il ya
une contrepartie c'est la responsabilité
il faut associer les deux on ne peut pas
toujours se cacher derrière une forme de
liberté quand on égorge des citoyens des
journalistes ou peu importe quand on
violente des femmes canton je me
souviens je suis allé deux fois en irak
et je me souviens du marché de mossoul
où des jeunes femmes étaient vendus
comme esclaves sexuelles pour 200
dollars
c'est cette idéologie de l'islamo
fascisme qu'on veut promouvoir en france
par nos fenêtres médiatiques
c'est ça qu'on veut encourager merci
oriane on va aborder la troisième partie
de l'émission bruno retailleau avec une
tout autre question est-ce que vous
condamnez le revirement nicolas sarkozy
sur le mariage pour tous 1 vous qui
avait été un de ses plus fervents
opposants vous allez dire dans quelle
guillaume daudin qui va également vous
interrogé plus largement sur
l'opposition sur la perspective de la
primaire nous écoutons d'abord franck
margerin quel président délégué du parti
chrétien démocrate sur la question du
mariage pour tous ceux semble surtout
qu'il a three les électeurs qui lui ont
fait confiance parce qu'il s'était
beaucoup positionner contre ce mariage
ont sectionné aujourd'hui change d'avis
je crois que comme d'habitude on fait
beaucoup de nos hommes politiques ont
comme programme
en fait les sondages et peut-être que
les sondages qu'il a reçues ont vu que
pour être capable de rejoindre ou de
rappeler un électorat du centre il a
préféré abandonner site et je pense que
il n'a pas de conviction réelle il n'a
peut-être pas eu je pense qu'il a signé
en fait sa défaite politique en
changeant radicalement position bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir à vous vous avez
peut-être lu le livre de nicolas sarkozy
ce jeu les reçus et je vais commencer à
le lire tout à l'heure voilà peut-être
vu en tout cas ses déclarations sur le
mariage pour tous
après avoir dit pendant la campagne pour
la présidence de l'ump qu'il était qu'on
pouvait réécrire voir abroger cette fois
ci il dit que le remède serait pire que
le mal
donc ils changent de position sur le
sujet quel est votre
continuons par rapport à ça m'a écouté
mon opinion n'a pas changé moi j'ai
combattu cette loi et les événements
m'ont renforcer dans la conviction je
pense qu' il ne faut surtout pas
marginalisés ou vouloir exclure de notre
communauté homosexuelle je pense que
consacrer un amour entre deux êtres
je n'y vois aucun inconvénient on peut
transformer justement ce texte avec une
réécriture donc une abrogation sur la
partie unions civiles mais la filiation
poser problème notamment avec la gpa
vous savez parfaitement que en france hp
a en réalité elle est interdite par le
code civil mais qu' on a eu ni président
totale puisque des sociétés américaines
viennent très régulièrement avec des
livres et qui montre les centaines de
femmes qui sont réduites au rang
finalement de bestiaux il faut les
choisir blonde petit etc et on loue des
ventres voilà parce que il faut donner
ce droit à l'enfant c'est ça que je
conteste voyez je pense que la gpa la
gestation pour autrui c'est une
déshumanisation c'est une
marchandisation règle donc moi je dis
oui
une union civile pour consacrer un amour
entre deux êtres deux femmes deux hommes
qui peuvent s'ébattre mariage mais mais
en revanche non parce que le problème du
mariage c'est que ça importe en droit
français c'est compliqué a à dire et
expliquer mais ça emporte cette
filiation et si vous donnez cette
filiation
il ya un moment donné vous buter sur
cette idée de la gestation pour autrui
de l'homme et moi la prestation pour
autrui
je pense que ça encourage toutes les
dérives
c'est en cours un sourire et je pense
que le droit à l'enfant ne doit pas
conduire
si vous voulez à ce genre de dérive là
on entend votre position qu est-ce que
ce qu'est ce que ça vous inspire du
candidat sarkozy
écoutez moi je suis président de groupe
je m'interdis les pitres je maintiens
que c'est un sujet l'interdît les
petites phrases sur ma famille politique
a alors décidé vous avez porté est un
sujet que j'ai portée et et moi je pense
que il faut être droit dans ses
convictions je lés dit tout à l'heure et
et je reste si vous voulez opposés et je
pense que alors évidemment il a tort
donc il a tort je suis pas sur sa
position il a peur de changer d'avis je
ne suis pas sur sa position
voilà et évidemment vous cherchez un tir
plein malsain mais toi dis la vérité je
le colombien est une question je peux au
moins affirmer ce à quoi je crois
qu'elles sont mes convictions sans taper
sur mais qui est la question de fond
derrière c est ce que ce sujet préoccupe
encore l'électorat au sens large et
l'électorat de droite au sens plus reste
quand je sortais de viol et non mais je
pense qu'il ya une évolution
effectivement et quand je il ya dix ans
l'union civile c'était compliqué à
expliquer ces voix là et je sens que
cette évolution et les murs et je pense
que les gens peuvent l'accepter mais je
pense que depuis le début ce qui a
suscité beaucoup beaucoup de
mobilisations s'étaient pas cela ce
n'était pas que la république consacre
ce lien dont ont besoin les personnes
dont on peut parfaitement et dans le
plus grand respect dans plus profond
respect le concevoir
c'est le problème de la filiation qu'il
conduit inévitablement alors à des
dérives
pourquoi madame taubira pourquoi est ce
que le ministère public aujourd'hui ne
poursuit pas les sociétés américaines
qui viennent faire du beurre sur la
faiblesse des autres et à l'étranger
pourquoi vous pourquoi alors que c'est
une contradiction avec l'état de droit
vous évoquez la filiation le droit à
l'enfant ça n'est pas forcément la
revendication des couples qui se marient
aujourd'hui ils revendaient suivant le
droit à l'égalité du mariage mairie de
douala à mon mariage
bien sûr mais vous savez ce concept
d'égalité voilà quand vous faites les
choses au nom de l'égalité et bien vous
avez un couple d'hommes qui dit moi
écouter je veux légalité et l'égalité
pour moi c'est le droit à l'enfant
puisque deux femmes peuvent recourir par
des moyens qui effectivement sont eux
aussi interdits à la pma nous on veut
aussi l'égalité et on veut pouvoir avoir
le droit à l'enfant
donc on voit bien que ce concept
d'égalité doit à mon avis être dépassé
par un autre concept qui est l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant et qui est un
concept par exemple de la nonna
disponibilité du corps humain de non
marchandisation du cerveau risation delà
de la position par rapport à la loi
taubira vous pensez que ça va être un
enjeu majeur de la de la primaire doit
vous dit vous savez à la fin on est déjà
là il ya la primaire effectivement elle
est allée à la fin de l'année
je pense que c'est sans doute un enjeu
je pense que et j'observe aujourd'hui
que la population française vit une
double crise une crise économique mais
en même temps une crise d'identité une
crise culturelle elle a besoin de
repères
le mariage ça fait partie des repères et
la filiation alors là je peux vous dire
que c'est inscrit dans les gènes de
notre société donc ça peut aussi
mobilisé un certain nombre vous imaginez
demain compte des maris jeu seulement
non non pas bon non mais il faut pas
caricaturer il faut pas craquer non je
crois que on profitera des mariés ceux
qui sont mariés voilà ce qu'ils ont
évidemment ça peut s'appliquer si le
texte est réformé ça ne peut s'appliquer
que pour l'avenir
on n'est pas des fous furieux il ne peut
pas y avoir de rétroactivité
dans ce domaine là et cet argument du
des mariages il est trop caricatural
veut dire je sais que ça peut
fonctionner autour d'un plateau mais non
faut être de ce point de vue là très
claire et elle sera en même temps voilà
c'est tout c'est simplement pour éviter
des dérives et je pense que notre
société tout entière
le paiera cher parce que à force
d'abandonner sur un certain nombre de
positions sur un certain nombre de
principes et des valeurs importantes que
on jette aux orties
on vous présente régulièrement on vous a
présenté régulièrement comme violoniste
c1 et peut-être qu'on a qu'on a ajouté à
votre à votre nom c'est toujours le cas
oui oui absolument que l'uma ma fidélité
de l'est pas indexé au sondage
j'ai vu qu'ils m'aident à remercier pour
votre pour votre amitié après votre
élection à la présidence de la région
oui vous savez quand on s'est connu à
l'époque course est connu j'étais son
vice président quand il était président
de la région des pays de la loire
donc il ya raison il ya des raisons pour
moi qui tiennent à une forme de relation
affective mais il ya aussi la raison de
la raison c'est à dire qu'il a je pense
un projet qui est sans doute assez
radicales pour transformer notre main
notre modèle économique français qui en
a besoin d'accords et plus prosaïquement
du côté de la fiction comme de la raison
vous n'êtes pas inquiet par les sondages
de la primaire qu'il conseille alors ils
le placent à 6,8 je vous répondrais
caracole dans les sondages vous n'allez
pas me faire dire le vert ce non
simplement observer ce qui s'est passé
au départemental et moi j'ai observé de
très très près ce qui s'est passé aux
régionales
les instituts de sondage désormais se
trompent régulièrement parce qu'il ya un
zapping très fréquents sur des
échantillons qui maîtrise bien pour une
élection normale mais pour une primaire
ils ne savent pas appréhender le corps
électoral
on ne sait pas du tout qu'il a voté
c'est pour ça que pour moi tout est
encore ouvert et j'ai une grande
confiance dans la candidature de
françois fillon
les choses vont s'ouvrir et ça sera à
partir dans quelques mois simplement que
les français de droite et du centre vont
commencer à s'intéresser dans ce débat
et c'est là que commencera seulement à
se cristalliser un certain nombre d'avis
mais moi je pense que françois fillon a
une double qualité il à la fois une
porte
si j'ose dire une forme de courage de
radicalité dans les propositions en
matière économique parce que si on ne
sort pas des 35 heures si on réforme pas
notre modèle on le perdra or moi je veux
l'ascenseur social
je veux une nouvelle espérance et en
même temps je pense qu'il a une forme de
sérénité d'apaisement et les français
peut-être peuvent en même temps de la
précision alors vous n'avez pas de doute
comme françois fillon on vous entend
bruno retailleau je vais vous faire
entendre quelqu'un qui a un doute
oui elle est si jeune nicolas sarkozy à
propos de sa propre candidature vous
surprendre mais réécouter la vous
réagirez la question de ma candidature
pas ma candidature c'est pas une
question automatique les semaines et les
mois qui viennent vous donneront à la
réponse bien sûr je n'irai que si c'est
utile bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
ep encore une fois le l'accueil sur ce
livre
l'intérêt apparemment que vous
manifestez pour skate dans notre quoi
qui encore de l'eau qui sort d'assurance
il a envie de recevoir des signaux
positifs
qu'est ce que vous lui envoyez comme
senior a décollé sarkozy au président de
notre mouvement c'est non mais c'est une
belle image c'est une belle image
moi je pense qu'il est sincère quand il
dit c'est à rien de surprenant venant de
nicolas sarkozy mais connaît plus plus
déterminés - - oui mais dans ses doutes
l'homme est sans doute beaucoup plus
complexe que la caricature que vous les
observateurs mais peut-être peut-être
aussi activités parfois dans le sens de
cette caricature c'est d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs un petit peu ce qui confesse
dans une ou deux pages que j'ai pu très
très vite parcourir non je pense qu'il a
il a des qualités
le problème en politique c'est qu' il
faut faire attention de ne pas être
aimée sur ce que nous ne sommes pas ou
être comment dirais je détestais pour ce
que nous ne sommes pas pour les mêmes
raisons aussi c'est compliqué et je
pense que moi je lui accorde de la
sincérité
en tout cas je peux vous assurer que
notre famille politique c'est mal portée
qui l'a jeté toute son énergie son
enthousiasme et son professionnalisme à
l'unité de cette famille et pour ça je
lui en suis reconnaissant
voilà vous parlé de cacophonie tout à
l'heure sur les 35 heures est quelque
chose qui a l'air assez clair dans le
chai les candidats de droite
oui cette série mère c'est le la volonté
d'une potion assez forte économiquement
dehors dans un sens libéral mais mesures
assez radical est-ce qu'il faut s'en
étonner donnez moi un seul pays d'europe
qui ait choisi cette règle et vous
parliez tout à l'heure aux nîmois
sévérisation des français c'est ça va
être le bon remède pour vous mais la
paupérisation des français je voudrais
je me suis fait comprendre tout à
l'heure en utilisant une statistique si
j'ose dire par rapport aux autres pays
européens
mais vous savez quand on a des taux de
croissance très faible le niveau de vie
baisse
je vais vous donner un exemple quand la
chine caracolait et bien vous avez un
doublement du niveau de vie tous les dix
ans avec la croissance américaine
vous avez un doublement du niveau de vie
tous les 24 ou 25 ans avec la croissance
de la france vous maintenez à peine le
niveau de vie dans la longue distance
donc on voit bien que ce qui est
abstrait une statistique une croissance
très basse à la traîne de tous les pays
européens
conduit inévitablement non seulement à
l'abaissement du pays mais surtout à
l'appauvrissement des français c'est ce
que je veux faire comprendre aux
français et je pense regarder tout
comparer des sondages mais je trouve que
les français aujourd'hui sont beaucoup
plus courageux qu'on ne le dit est
beaucoup plus près aux réformes qu'on ne
le pense et que les politiques côté
concours lépine je voyais ce matin
laurent wauquiez proposer 42 eur 2 et
dans le temps de travail
oui non mais bien sûr l'important
l'important c'est de vouloir sortir des
35 heures de faire ce que les grands
pays européens ont pu faire de faire un
certain nombre de réformes qui
permettront n'ont pas encore une fois de
jeter à l'eau le modèle notre modèle
social et économique mais qui
permettront de le réinventer
voilà est de faire en sorte qu' on
puisse refaire fonctionner l'ascenseur
social
parce qu'aujourd'hui souvent ce que
pensent les familles pour leur enfant
c'est que demain demain sera pire qui
hier alors que traditionnellement depuis
les trente glorieuses on avait eu cette
idée que demain sera meilleur
qu'aujourd'hui et surtout qui hier donc
là il ya une régression et pour en
sortir faut réformer c'est ce qu'ont
fait les autres il faut que la france
aujourd'hui le fasse
comment est-ce que vous parvenez à
cumuler aujourd'hui aux nouvelles
fonctions de patron de région et puis de
patron des sénateurs
c'est terrible à ces terribles un an
mais je suis je les dis pendant toute la
campagne des drones qui sait c'est aux
dépens de de vous-même propre sentais si
j'ose dire non mais j'ai dit c'est une
question qui m'a souvent été posée et je
les dis pendant toute la campagne vous
pourrez regarder les différents débats
que j'ai pu faire
j'ai dit écoutez oui je vais vous dire
pourquoi je souhaite que avoir un pied
en région et rien pied au parlement tout
simplement parce que les élus hors sol
on n'en mourra si demain au sénat le
sénat en plus il est leur présentation
la représentation des territoires c'est
quelque chose que les français peuvent
comprendre
écoutez je vais vous dire quand vous les
sondés ils sont tous contre le cumul
mais ce que j'observe c'est que j'ai
encore gagné les élections
ça fait une petite trentaine d'années
que j'ai dû gagner une dizaine
d'élections toujours en six jours dire
par le cumul simplement un certain
nombre de gagnants aux énormes et
démissionner
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
tant que la france et la france tant que
les décisions se prennent à paris il
vaut mieux avoir de l'influencé à paris
pour pouvoir aussi servir son territoire
ne même qu'il faut qu'à partir de son
territoire regarder préjudice écologique
voilà moi c'est mon expérience avec la
marée noire de l'erika
je les portais depuis 13 ans le
préjudice écologique aucun écho le
portel voilà il a fallu que ce soit
quelqu'un de terrain qui avec une marée
noire qui puisse l'inscrire
j'espère demain dans le code civil alors
j'ai une verdure question pour vous
bruno retailleau est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre la grâce de jacqueline
sauvage vous avez entendu parler de
cette femme qui a été condamnée à 10 ans
de prison pour avoir tué son mari
violent c'est la question de la légitime
défense qui doit s'appliquer il ya une
pétition qui a signé par des
responsables politiques de droite de
gauche vous même vous êtes prêt à c'est
un cas qui est troublant du très
honnêtement je fais très attention parce
que je ne n'ai pas étudié en tout cas
c'est une personnalité et un cas de
figure qui provoque beaucoup d'émotion
voilà malheureusement elle a tiré dans
le dos mais ce qu'elle avait subi ce que
ses enfants avaient subi pendant des
années et des années
je pense qu'effectivement il pourrait y
avoir une grâce
maintenant c'est au président de
république je suis trop attaché aux
institutions pour que je puisse diminuer
de l'indépendance et la capacité de
jugement alors à l'elysée on dit qu'on a
bien entendu l'appel oui mais qu' il ya
une procédure
ils ont respecté et qu'il faut des
circonstances exceptionnelles les ont
réunis ces circonstances exceptionnelles
on l'a vu aux côtés je n'ai pas étudié
le dossier donc je n'accorde dans une
rue de chose de grave c'est que quelque
chose de grave y ait énormément
souffrance il est bien mort je pense que
justement
l'elysée fait bien de rappeler qu'il
faut les procédures parce que sinon si
c'est seulement des appels des pétitions
et l'émotion un jour on peut se tromper
peut-être que là c'est justifié alors
évidemment elle a déjà fait je crois
trois ans de prison simplement j'observe
que il ya aussi des criminels vraiment
criminel qui de temps en temps par
vraiment trop trop vite de la prison
qu'on des remises de peine qui ne semble
vraiment trop trop rapide pour les
crimes qu'ils ont commis
merci merci merci bruno retailleau
rouler ce fil est donc un entrepôt de
vos activités merci d'être venus là
pendant une heure sur collectionna vent
sera tout s'est très vite
qui